está este lanzamiento de la comisión de
la verdad llega en un momento también en
el que hay un cambio histórico en el
gobierno de colombia un gobierno más
progresista es más de izquierda que
desde un comienzo digamos estuvo
abierto a apoyar la implementación del
acuerdo de paz y recoger las acciones de
la comisión y de todo el sistema de
justicia y creo que eso definitivamente
va a facilitar que esta era que
transitamos en la construcción de paz
sea más
llegué más y tenga más fondo más
profundidad porque los cuatro años que
pasamos con el gobierno dejando que no
fueron para nada sencillos para esta
comisión de la verdad en la construcción
del relato en la divulgación y en la
búsqueda de involucrar actores que un
poco en estado distantes a esta realidad